more bodies are being retrieved from
graves at the shakahola forest in
malindi along the canyon Coast
most of the people who died here were
women and children they are said to have
starved to death after their Pastor told
them they'll go directly to heaven
forensic experts are taking samples from
the remains to determine the cause of
death all these bodies we have exhumed
here
will be done
we also collecting samples from the
graves and you've seen Mass Graves we
are collecting samples those who will go
those soil samples will go through
various tests one to
um identify whether there was any
poisoning
this Forest lies on more than 300
hectares of land the investigative team
here says it's doing what it can to
cover more ground police are looking for
more Graves they believe that they have
not even scratched the surface some of
the bodies are decomposed that means
this has been going on for a while
some relatives have traveled from
different parts of the country to look
for their loved ones
last year my relatives told us they're
going for a mission we were worried
because they were vague about the
mission
my brother-in-law recently called he
said he was hiding in the bush with
others I'm afraid they might be starving
themselves
Paul McKenzie is the pastor suspected of
being involved in this case he's known
to the police he has been arrested
several times but he gets off because of
a lack of evidence
he appeared in court last month after he
was accused of causing the deaths of two
children at his farm he was released on
bail and that's when the police raided
the farm
human rights activists say the local
Administration failed to protect a
vulnerable community that was under its
care some previous years we had gotten
this report but the reports from the
chief
and the administration within were not
taken with a lot of seriousness
many questions remain unanswered but for
now the priority is identifying the
victims and how they died as well as
reaching those who may still be hiding
out in the forest
County Kenya